let's pivot to that point peter because
the athletics article
sparked a reaction mark rogers the
russell wilson agent went on the record
with adam schefter and said
number one
russell wilson has not requested a trade
my understanding is he did that because
he's irritated that people have presumed
that russell wilson has asked for a
trade but number two
he does want to play for seattle but if
for some reason
if for some reason there would be a
trade
russell would wave his no trade clause
for four teams and he named them on the
record when has that ever happened
well not usually it's through a leak or
something on the record the agent says
he'll play for the cowboys the bears the
saints or the raiders i fell out of my
chair when i saw that yesterday so that
that is the most passive aggressive
aggressive aggressive non-trade trade
demand i've ever seen he i look at and i
say guy wants out and they've sent an
engraved invitation to four franchises
to go ahead and put your best offers
together and let's see what happens
and i think you know three teams
you know are pretty easy to understand
you know john gruden has a love fest
with russell wilson
uh you know dallas
uh you know obviously that's a franchise
that that many players have that feeling
about sean payton uh you know obviously
also is is in that you know if you're a
quarterback you want to play for sean
payton
the bears took me by surprise a little
bit mike and that's
that's because you know they seem to be
on a precipice right now
you know they
you know you you might say well they got
a good defense which they do
you know it's not the best defense in
the league but they they have a good
defense
my question is
you know
what kind of offense do they have
and would russell wilson be actually
going to an offense
that that you know he wouldn't be
running for his life again just like he
is doing right now i might even say that
the bear's offensive line
you know has has less upside than
seattle's does
but whatever whatever that is
you know that was when i read that
yesterday i just said to myself
that's a while
when you not only say
he we would wave the no trade clause for
certain teams but you actually name them
i
that is basically saying we'd like you
to go and talk to those teams
basically
well and it's not even that it is hey
team start calling the seahawks because
we'd been hearing teams had been calling
and we hadn't been hearing that john
schneider is hanging up the phone and
and it was also a message to the other
teams out there that may be calling
don't waste your time unless you're on
this list don't waste your time
russell's not taking a trade to any
other teams now it could be that mark
rogers held a team or two in his pocket
because maybe the seahawks come out of
this feeling like a win for them if they
can direct russell wilson to one of the
teams not on the list but maybe it's a
team that mark rogers and russell wilson
will go to anyway i don't want to go too
deep into the weeds with that
possibility of of a psychological battle
between the two sides but i won't rule
out the possibility there's another team
or two on that list but the four that
came out yesterday peter it really was
stunning and the bears i agree with you
the most surprising we we talk all the
time about the bears haven't had a great
quarterback a truly great quarterback
since sid luckman you could argue for
the storied franchise history of the
chicago bears russell wilson walks
through the door as the best quarterback
in team history
yeah he wouldn't walk in the door as a
better quarterback well certainly
if if you really appreciate football
history russell wilson is not better
than sid luckman right now
but he might become better than sid
luckman um
the issue i think is
that one did stick out but the one other
thing mike when you start naming teams i
think then you start looking at each one
of those teams and looking at their
quarterback situations
and basically saying that what really
does make the most sense
and you know look
i have no idea how to see how the new
orleans saints would figure this out
all i know is that mickey loomis would
figure it out
uh it would be ugly
there would be some respected players
valued players
uh that would have to be
let go
and or traded
however it works out
but
if they could have russell wilson on
their team there's no question in my
mind that they would do whatever it
would take to be able to get them
well what we're going to do we're going
to focus on each of the four teams and
let's make sure there's no further
business to be done with the bears
before we focus on the saints i think
you and i both agree that the bears
should be as of this moment as of
yesterday when that tweet landed
figuring out what they could put
together to get
russell wilson whether that means throw
khalil mack onto the pile i mean
whatever it's going to take what is the
offer that we could put together to get
a solution for the next 10 years or so
to our quarterback issues that have been
unsolvable at least since the days of
sid luckman so
uh
the problem is
they they well they haven't been using
first round picks anyway because of the
khalil mack trade but you know it's not
like they're one of these teams that's
sitting on multiple first round picks
this year and next year like the jets
they'd have to get very creative they'd
have to tie up draft picks multiple
years into the future but i think you
and i both agree
that regardless of whether or not the
seahawks trade russell wilson the bears
or anyone else the bears top priority
right now given the fact that there's no
other clear option out there to upgrade
the quarterback position over mitchell
trubisky and nick foles the bears should
be in the lab coming up with some kind
of an offer for russell wilson
and as much as everybody's going to say
no no no you can't do this
i think a reasonable offer would be mac
this year's one and two future ones
and everybody would say oh way too much
way too much well wait a second
the one this year is 20th overall
and one in the next two years
would be probably
you know at best in the teens
so it's not like they're going to be
trading
uh you know the in in future years uh
the the sixth pick in the draft when
russell wilson's your quarterback you
are going to be a competitive team
you're not going to be below 500 that's
all there is to it
but having said that mike i think that
the only way that the bears could make
it worth it because they really don't
have
the offensive pieces to make it worth it
okay the only way that in my opinion
they make it worth it is to chisel away
a little bit at that defense
and and they they gave up multiple first
round picks to get cleo max several
years ago but that was several years ago
and this is russell wilson this is the
position they have been failing to
properly address for decades they
thought it was going to be jay cutler he
racked up a lot of stats but not a whole
lot of success for the chicago bears all
right the saints now i've been i've been
percolating on that one too because i
agree with you that look drew brees and
we talked earlier in the week until drew
brees retires who the hell knows what
he's going to do maybe seeing tom brady
win a super bowl at 43 is convincing
drew brees to give it one more run even
though all signs point to him retiring
but if he's out of the picture you got
taysom hill under contract you've got
jameis winston that they're thinking
about finding a way to bring back
if i'm sean payton
i say my god what i could do with
russell wilson in this offense because
he's basically drew brees with a liver
arm who can get the ball down the field
who can make things happen
in the passing game where i don't need
to put taysom hill out there and you
know peter i think the package starts
with
taste some hill plus draft picks taysom
hill plus draft picks for russell wilson
and michael thomas would sign on for it
right now he posted a picture of himself
with russell wilson yesterday once that
word came out yeah you don't need taste
you don't need the taysom hill change of
pace if you've got a quarterback who can
fire the ball all the way down the field
and force the defense to cover all of
the green real estate and uh i agree
with you between mickey loomis and sean
payton
even if you don't do it you have to take
24 to 48 hours and fully explore what
you could get away with
by way of giving up guys you currently
have making it work under the salary cap
and getting russell wilson and it would
be 19 million they'd have to find to pay
him this year
it's worth every second that they would
invest to see if they could solve that
puzzle
you know i think one of the interesting
parts of the saints if the saints did
get involved mike is that
they don't have to go to their incumbent
quarterback and have the awkward
conversation
you know if sean payton called jameis
winston and even though he's not the
incumbent quarterback
if he calls taysom hill and and and and
jameis winston he basically just has to
say to him hey guys russell wilson you
know
it's pretty understandable
and
and and and i think
that because the saints have drafted so
well
in the last two or three years
you know mickey loomis jeff ireland
their personnel staff has been
absolutely terrific because they've
drafted so well mike
they have
they have a lot of pieces in place
what would happen if the
main
uh focus
of the seahawks for instance was ryan
ramczyk
and he could say hey look you get a top
10
offensive tackle in the nfl maybe top
five
okay
and you don't try to make this a volume
thing you just try to say
we're going to get
a piece to the offensive line puzzle
that we've never been able to get
if if it's ram chick let's say and taste
some hill
and draft choices to me that is a that's
a bit of a fascinating offer to at least
get the ball rolling uh
with the saints and the seahawks and you
know with with the the saints
particularly
the approach
other than coming up with a great offer
and putting it on the table maybe the
saints are the ones who are best suited
by calling the seahawks and saying just
tell us what you want just tell us what
you want and we'll see if we can work it
out you tell us what you'd love to get
you tell us which players you want and
we'll see if we can work it out because
the saints are already standing on the
brink
of a major upheaval
in their rot there's 70 million over the
cap now those numbers can add up quickly
with you know just this guy here goes oh
there's 10 million that we found and
that you know you can you can make it
happen quickly and get under the cap if
you want to but i think with so many
veteran players that they may be
thinking about cutting but they've kept
their their cards close to the vest find
out who the seahawks want because you
may get lucky the seahawks may want a
guy that you're thinking about moving on
from anyway that's why i'm saying it's
valuable for the saints to call the
seahawks and say tell us what you want
because they may want somebody that the
saints no longer need
and mike just remember you know the
saints and the seahawks have a little
bit of a history because of the jimmy
graham max unger trade a few years ago
and
i'll say this
mickey loomis sean payton john schneider
they all have something in common they
went to the jimmy johnson school of
personnel you're never married to any
player you know you you you'll listen
and and that to me is why
this this is an intriguing thing they
they have they have a history they've
done business and they are not afraid
as to the raiders i suspect john gruden
who's got that that well-known history
of getting up at 3 45 in the morning
i i suspect he hasn't even gone home
after getting the news yesterday that
his team is one of the four finalists
for a potential russell wilson trade and
you know he's scowling with the eyebrow
and him and mayok are in a room and
they're drinking coffee and you know
they're they're taking no doughs or
whatever the kids take nowadays to stay
awake although i'm sure there's probably
some illegal things the kids take
nowadays to stay awake but nevertheless
i digress
the the john gruden has to be
completely and totally
smitten with the idea of getting russell
wilson and not just because as i said
yesterday on pftpm he doesn't need to
get on a step stool to see eye to eye
with his quarterback for a change this
is the guy that he's been
pining for and just has never had the
opportunity to get
mike
i've said this on many occasions and it
bears repeating today
john gruden's favorite quarterback is
always the one he doesn't have
and in my opinion
that is the russell wilson
that if if you know
you just said it you put it exactly the
right way john gruden
would be
so highly excited
by
something like this
and and look i don't care what anybody
says
you just get the feeling
looking at the raiders listening to uh
you know gruden and all that that
they are treading water
you know
they have drafted i think pretty well
in the mayak area it hasn't shown up
entirely yet okay but i think they have
drafted pretty well
and i think in general when i look at
the raiders i look at a team
that just is under achieving
it just is
they're not as good as they should be
and that has to drive john gruden and
mike mayok
crazy
and so what is the way to fix that
you know blow something up on the team
you know tell everybody that this is not
business as usual we are not in this
business to go nine and seven
we're in this business to win a super
bowl and you get a guy to come in
who is in in this in the last decade of
football who's really the ultimate
overachiever and he's going to come to
vegas and you can tell everybody on your
team
you know he he's going to walk in his
first press conference really wherever
he is i will not rest until we win a
super bowl in this city
god it's going to be weird to hear him
say anything other than go hawks at the
end of interviews and press conferences
but uh
i still feel like it's inevitable one of
these days before he ends his career
that's going to happen what do you do if
you're the raiders beyond derek carr
obviously multiple draft picks are there
other players that jump out to you that
they could they could part ways with you
know defensively they got a lot of guys
who who haven't been as good as they
need to be those may not be guys the
seahawks want offensively
you know they don't they don't really
need a henry rugs they've got dk metcalf
would they want josh jacobs would that
make it a sweeter package for the
seahawks i mean jacobs has shown he can
get it done and i'm not so sure gruden
would want to part ways with him
you know two guys come to mind right
away one is jonathan abram the safety
even though he has an injury history
uh pairing him with georgia george adams
and perry him
uh you know with jamal adams in the
secondary to me
would be
would create an absolutely fearsome
secondary and the other guy who really
occurs to me when i just start thinking
about it is a second receiving weapon
like hunter renfro and you know to me
when i think of young players who could
make us better right away those are the
two guys i think of
that i would want included in the trade
other than derrick carr
last but definitely not least how about
them cowboys now look a dak prescott
trade would not be practical because
first they'd have to get him to sign the
franchise tender at 37.68 million carry
around that cap space trade that cap
space to the seahawks hope the seahawks
can then take that and turn it into a
long-term deal seahawks meanwhile have
no way of knowing whether to what extent
that prescott's recovering from that
badly broken ankle so
this would be for the cowboys
come up with a huge trade package not
involving your current quarterback
letting your current quarterback walk
away as a free agent
getting a compensatory draft pick for
him next year
and otherwise putting together whatever
it would take to get the seahawks to
give you russell wilson i feel like of
the four teams on the list even though
the cowboys are the name that i've been
hearing consistently for more than a
year as a russell wilson destination i
feel like it's too much work for the
cowboys and it breaks too much from what
they're trying to do they're still tied
to dak prescott and even though russell
wilson's better all due respect to
everyone involved i don't see the
cowboys making the same kind of urgent
effort that these other teams would do
you agree
i disagree
and the reason i disagree is that
i think i think if there's a will
there's a way
and in my opinion
stephen jones and jerry jones
have to be thinking for two years we've
tried to get a deal done with a
quarterback who we love
and
time and time and time again
it looks like he wants to go the kirk
cousins route
and
if this guy
doesn't want to sign with us
and is more interested in testing the
market
well why can't we
take an incredible amount
of bad medicine
in one year
and it could mean
that you lose three or four players that
you really don't want to lose
and you know but to me
this has to be about the end game and
russell wilson in 21 22 23 24
he's your guy long term
and when the cap goes up
we're going to be able to fix things we
are going to put three or four contracts
way out into the future now we're going
to redo amari cooper we're going to redo
all of these guys
and you know to me
that's what i'd be thinking if i were
the dallas cowboys it's the same thing
mike i would be thinking in a different
way if i were the saints
yeah it's impossible but figure it out
yeah i i uh
two last points and then we got to go to
break i think we've broken the record
for the longest first segment of the
show ever one whoever inherits russell
wilson is inheriting the problems the
seahawks currently have number one you
want a guy who wants to be involved so
you better be ready to make him involved
if you're going to get russell wilson
and also i got three quick points to
make two
he loves to come back to the trough and
get market value contracts you got to be
ready for that mark rogers is going to
want to try to break the bank sooner
rather than later if he has a new team
and three this is the one thing we
haven't mentioned and it's a real factor
mrs russell wilson you know a couple of
years ago when this bubbled up peter
there was talk about the new york giants
there was talk about ciara wanting to be
in a market where it's more conducive to
her career
we don't know how much
she has been and continues to be
poking
russell let's get this done let's get
this done let's get this done that's a
very real factor in in this specific
situation that has yet to really be
focused upon
but
this if this is russell wilson's life
every day that would explain why there
seems to be an accelerated effort for
him to make this happen sooner rather
than later
yeah but i think
and i do not deny that that could well
be a part of it mike
but she's not the one who has to go to
that facility every day and apparently
be very frustrated by the work
conditions that's why i think this is
far more russell wilson related than
wife related right i agree but it's a
factor it's a factor
and uh i think it's a factor that we
need to pay attention to is we wonder
when and if this is going to happen in
my mind it's no longer if it's just a
question of when whether it's this year
next year the year after the year after
that it's it i i feel like we're
eventually going to see
russell wilson in the new uniform and it
won't be nearly as jarring as seeing tom
brady in a tampa bay buccaneers uniform
and brady is the one to blame for all
this stuff that's gone on with
quarterbacks with the exception of
deshawn watson because watson's problems
existed before tom brady was tossing a
super bowl trophy from one boat to
another
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports